TO BOOST VACCINATIONS, WHICH
CANNOT COME SOON ENOUGH.
NEARLY 1,500 AMERICANS ARE DYING
EVERYDAY FROM COVID.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THEM
UNVACCINATED.
HOSPITALIZATIONS NOW NATIONWIDE
AMONG ADULTS ARE DOWN FROM THEIR
PEAK, BUT THERE ARE A RECORD
NUMBER OF CHILDREN WHO ARE NOW
BATTLING COVID IN THE HOSPITAL.
MANY OF WHOM OF COURSE CANNOT
GET VACCINATED YET.
CHILDREN NOW REPRESENT MORE THAN
A QUARTER OF WEEKLY COVID-19
CASES NATIONWIDE, THAT'S
ACCORDING TO THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS.
>> THE RISE IN CHILDREN'S CASES
COMES AS KIDS HEAD BACK TO
SCHOOL AND BACK TO CLASSROOMS
WITH VARYING DEGREES OF
PROTECTION DEPENDING ON THE
STATE.
OVERNIGHT A FEDERAL JUDGE DENIED
A REQUEST TO TEMPORARILY BLOCK
TENNESSEE GOVERNOR'S BILL LEE'S
RULE THAT LET'S PARENTS OPT OUT
OF SCHOOL MASK MANDATES FOR
THEIR CHILDREN.
LAST MONTH WE TOLD YOU ABOUT A
FIERY SCHOOL BOARD MEETING IN
TENNESSEE WHERE A FATHER WHO
ADVOCATED FOR MASKS WAS
THREATENED BY ANGRY MASK
OPPONENTS WHILE HE TRIED TO
DRIVE AWAY.
LOOK AT THIS.
THE FATHER'S NAME IS MICHAEL
MILLER.
AND HIS SON JUST TESTED POSITIVE
FOR COVID.
AND MICHAEL JOINS US NOW.
HIS BOYS ATTEND WILLIAMSON
COUNTY SCHOOLS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH
US THIS MORNING, MICHAEL.
I KNOW YOUR SIXTH GRADER HAS NOW
TESTED POSITIVE.
LET ME START BY ASKING HOW HE'S
DOING.
>> GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU FOR ASKING.
WE'RE VERY FORTUNATE HIS CASE IS
VERY MINOR.
HIS SYMPTOMS ARE RATHER MILD.
HE'S DOING OKAY AND ACTING LIKE
HIMSELF WHAT STARTED AS A MILD
FEVER BECAME AT THIS POINT JUST
SOME CONGESTION AND A COUGH.
>> THAT'S GOOD NEWS.
BUT I DO UNDERSTAND HE HAS A
CLASSMATE WHO IS NOT DOING AS
WELL.
>> YES.
IT VARIES THE SYMPTOMS VARY
CHILD TO CHILD AND ONE OF HIS
CLASSMATES ACTUALLY JUST GOT OUT
OF THE HOSPITAL FOR BEING IN THE
HOSPITAL FOR FIVE DAYS WITH
COVID-19.
>> THAT'S TROUBLING.
AS WE SEE THE NUMBER OF CASES
RISE, WE SEE THE NUMBER OF
HOSPITALIZATIONS RISE AMONG KIDS
WHICH IS CERTAINLY SOMETHING TO
BE CONCERNED ABOUT AND A NUMBER
OF KIDS IN YOUR SON'S SCHOOL
HAVE BEEN INFECTED?
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
SO, THE SIXTH GRADER IS -- KIDS
ARE BETWEEN 11 AND 12 YEARS OLD.
SO A LOT CANNOT BE VACCINATED.
IN THE LAST TWO WEEKS IN THE
SCHOOL OVER 20% OF THEM HAVE
BEEN INFECTED.
>> AND THE MASK RULES AS THEY
STAND ARE THE SCHOOL WANTS YOU
TO WEAR MASKS BUT THEY CAN'T
REQUIRE IT.
YOU CAN OPT OUT, CORRECT?
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
THERE'S THREE DIFFERENT OPT-OUTS
REALLY THE OVERRIDING OPT-OUT AT
THIS POINT IS EXECUTIVE ORDER 84
THE GOVERNOR'S ORDER WHICH
DICTATES THAT ANY SCHOOL THAT
HAS A MASK MANDATE HAS TO GIVE
AN OPT-OUT FOR WHAT THE
SUPERINTENDENT APTLY TERMS IS
THE I DON'T WANT IT CLAUSE.
I DON'T WANT TO WEAR A MASK, SO
YOU DON'T HAVE TO.
>> HOW MANY KIDS ARE MASKED AND
UNMASKED AT YOUR KID'S SCHOOL?
>> AT THE MIDDLE SCHOOL LEVEL
THERE'S 30%, HIGH SCHOOLS UP TO
50% AND AT THE ELEMENTARY
SCHOOLS BETWEEN 13 AND 30%.
>> HOW DOES YOUR SON -- HOW DID
YOUR SON FEEL ABOUT GOING TO
SCHOOL WEARING MASKS?
IS THERE A STIGMA TO BE MASKED
AND UNMASKED?
>> IN HIS EYES, NO.
WE HAD THEM ONLINE LAST YEAR.
HE'S EXCITED TO BE BACK IN THE
BUILDING AND THRILLED TO BE BACK
WITH HIS FRIENDS.
HE HAS NO PROBLEM WITH IT.
THERE ARE LOTS OF CHILDREN WHO
PARENTS TOLD US THEY ENCOURAGE
MASKS IN THEIR HOME, SEND THE
CHILD WITH A MASK AND THE CHILD
IS NOT WEARING A MASK BECAUSE
SOME OF THE FRIENDS ARE NOT.
SO IT'S PEER PRESSURE.
BE VERY CLEAR NO ONE IS TEASING
ANYBODY, THAT'S NOT HAPPENING,
AT LEAST NOT IN OUR SCHOOLS
THAT'S NOT HAPPENING OR
HAPPENING ELSEWHERE.
BUT, THE KIDS ARE NOT WEARING
THE MASK BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT
TO FACE THE RISK OF BEING
TEASED.
>> SO WE HAVE SEEN THAT VIDEO OF
YOU BEING THREATENED.
IT'S REALLY SCARY STUFF FROM A
MONTH AGO.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS NOW OR
THINK BACK TO THAT MOMENT, HOW
DOES SEEING OR KNOWING ABOUT
THIS MOMENT MAKE YOU FEEL NOW
THAT YOUR SON GOT COVID?
>> I HATE TO SAY VINDICATED BUT
SOME OF IT IS THAT.
I STILL WHEN I SEE THIS, THIS IS
SO INAPPROPRIATE AND SO BEYOND
THE SCOPE OF WHAT REALITY HAS
BECOME.
IT'S REALITY OF WHAT'S BECOME AT
SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS
UNFORTUNATELY THAT YOU'VE GOT
THESE MOBS SHOWING UP ON ONE
SIDE, THE LOUD MINORITY HOW I
REFER TO THEM BECAUSE THE SILENT
MAJORITY WANTS MASKS THEY'RE NOT
SHOWING UP.
WE NEED MORE OF THOSE PEOPLE
SHOWING UP AT THE SCHOOL BOARD
MEETINGS AND SHARING THEIR PIECE
AND WRITING TO THE SCHOOL BOARD
MEETINGS AND NEXT YEAR RUNNING
FOR SCHOOL BOARD.
WE NEED MORE PEOPLE WILLING TO
STEP FORWARD AND ADVOCATE FOR
COMMON SENSE.
WHAT YOU SAW THERE THAT NIGHT
WAS A WELL ORGANIZED MACHINE
THAT YOU'RE SEEING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
>> I GUESS WHAT I'M ASKING IS
NOW IS THAT EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE
WORRIED ABOUT IS EXACTLY WHAT
YOU HAPPENED WHAT YOU WERE
WORRIED ABOUT.
>> 110%.
ABSOLUTELY.
THAT'S EVERY PARENT'S GREATEST
FEAR.
WE KEPT OUR KIDS HOME LAST YEAR
TO KEEP THEM SAFE FROM COVID AND
WE SEND THEM BACK INTO SCHOOL
AND WITHIN A MONTH HERE HERE WE
GO.
EVERYTHING WE TRIED TO AVOID.
>> LISTEN, I HOPE HIS RECOVERY
CONTINUES.
I KNOW YOU HAVE ANOTHER SON WHO
HAS TO QUARANTINE AT HOME
BECAUSE HE HAS A BROTHER WHO HAS
IT.
>> YES.
>> HOPEFULLY THEY'LL BOTH BE
BACK IN SCHOOL AND HOPEFULLY
THEY'LL BE AS SAFE AS THEY CAN.
MICHAEL, WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING
WITH US.
>> THANK YOU.
>>> HOSPITALS IN PARTS OF IDAHO
HAVE BEGUN RATIONING HEALTHCARE
WITH PATIENTS OVERWHELMING
EMERGENCY ROOMS.
THAT MEANS THAT DOCTORS CAN
CHOOSE WHO TO ADMIT INTO THE
SCARCE NUMBER OF INTENSIVE CARE
UNITS BASED ON WHO IS MOST
LIKELY TO SURVIVE.
OTHER PATIENTS MAY BE PLACED IN
HOSPITAL CLASSROOMS OR
CONFERENCE ROOMS BECAUSE THERE
ISN'T ENOUGH SPACE OR MAYBE
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH STAFFING.
NEXT DOOR IN OREGON HOSPITALS
ARE ALSO SEEING THEIR HIGHEST
NUMBER OF COVID PATIENTS THAT
THEY HAVE EVER SEEN, JUST LOOK
AT THE CHART HERE.
JOINING US NOW IS DR. BRIAN
HOYT, THE EMERGENCY MEDICAL
DIRECTOR AT McKENZIE MEDICAL
CENTER IN SPRINGFIELD, OREGON.
DOCTOR, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING WITH US.
OKAY.
SO WE'RE SEEING THIS MOVE TO A
CRISIS STANDARD OF CARE IN
NEIGHBORING IDAHO.
WHAT ARE YOU SEEING?
WHAT ARE YOU DOING WHERE YOU
ARE?
>> WELL, IT'S BEEN A CHALLENGING
SUMMER ALREADY BECAUSE OF OUR
NURSE STAFFING SHORTAGES AND
THEN JUST ABOUT THREE WEEKS AGO
WE HAD A HUGE SPIKE IN THE DELTA
VARIANT COME THROUGH OUR
COMMUNITY.
AND WE WERE AVERAGING ABOUT FIVE
COVID POSITIVE PATIENTS IN OUR
HOSPITAL OF 92 MEDICAL BEDS A
DAY.
AND IN ABOUT 3 TO 4 DAYS WE WENT
UP TO 51 COVID POSITIVE PATIENTS
IN OUR HOSPITAL ADMITTED WITH
OUR ICU COMPLETELY FULL, 15 BEDS
ALL ON VENTILATORS AND WE RAN
OUT OF VENTILATORS.
WE HAD TO BORROW FOUR FROM A
NEIGHBORING HOSPITAL.
AND IN TWO DAYS THOSE WERE BEING
USED AND IT'S JUST BEEN A REAL
STRAIN ON THE WHOLE SYSTEM.
LIKE YOU HAD MENTIONED, WE HAD
TO SHUT DOWN THE ENERGIES, OPEN
UP OUR POST ANESTHESIA RECOVERY
UNIT IN ORDER TO MAKE A SECOND
ICU FOR MORE BEDS AND WE EX
EXPANDED UP TO 110 BED CAPACITY,
BUT EVERYBODY IS STRETCHED REAL
THIN.
WE'RE USING ALL THE RESOURCES WE
CAN JUST TO TRY TO TAKE THE BEST
CARE OF PATIENTS AND IT'S
GETTING VERY CHALLENGING.
>> I KNOW THAT THINGS HAVE
LEVELLED OFF A LITTLE BIT SINCE
THIS SPIKE THAT YOU JUST HAD AT
THE END OF AUGUST.
BUT THAT YOU'RE CONCERNED THAT
MOVING INTO THE SCHOOL YEAR HERE
IT'S GOING TO GENERATE MORE
CASES.
YOU KNOW, AS WE TALK ABOUT
THIS -- I THINK THIS IS WHAT'S
VERY SCARY FOR PEOPLE BUT IT'S
THE REALITY.
IF THINGS GET BAD ENOUGH,
DOCTORS, HOSPITALS HAVE TO START
MAKING CHOICES.
YOU KNOW, WHAT DOES THAT LOOK
LIKE IF YOU GET TO THAT POINT?
>> WELL, WE DEFINITELY HAD
MOMENTS DURING THAT BIG SURGE
ABOUT A WEEK AGO WHERE WE WERE
SITTING AROUND THE TABLE IN THE
ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICE TALKING
ABOUT WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO?
WE WERE REALLY AT THE LIMIT?
WE WERE SCRAMBLING TO DECIDE ARE
WE GOING TO HAVE TO START
DECIDING WHO GETS CARE, NOT
CARE, MOVE PATIENTS TO OTHER
PARTS OF THE STATE OR OTHER
NEARBY STATES.
AND SO WE DID SIT AND TALK SOME
ABOUT THE PROTOCOL AND HOW THAT
WORKS.
THERE ARE PLANS IN PLACE TO TRY
TO MAKE THE BEST DECISIONS WITH
ETHICAL DISCERNMENTS AND IT JUST
BREAKS YOUR HEART TO HAVE TO
HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS,
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU KNOW THAT
THE MAJORITY OF THESE PEOPLE,
90% OF THE SICK PEOPLE COMING IN
ARE NOT VACCINATED AND THERE IS
A TREATMENT OUT THERE WITH
VACCINE THAT WILL LESSEN THE
SEVERITY OF THE SURGE TO OUR
WHOLE COMMUNITY.
>> YEAH.
LOOK, THESE ARE IT'S
UNNECESSARY, RIGHT?
OVER TIME I WONDER HAVE YOU SEEN
A DIFFERENT -- HAVE YOU SEEN A
DIFFERENT PROFILE WHEN IT COMES
TO THE PATIENTS THAT YOU HAVE
COMING IN?
>> WELL, YEAH.
I THINK IN THE FIRST WAVE OF
COVID IT WAS -- WE DIDN'T HAVE A
VACCINE, HEALTHCARE WORKERS
FINALLY GOT VACCINATED.
THAT HELPED WITH OUR SECURITY
AND TAKING CARE OF PATIENTS.
AND IT WAS PRETTY MUCH ALL
COMERS.
BUT IN THIS LAST DELTA SURGE AT
THE END OF THE SUMMER, IT'S
PRETTY MUCH ALL UNVACCINATED
PEOPLE.
AND SOME OF THEM ARE IN DENIAL
THAT THEY HAVE THE ILLNESS.
SOME OF THEM ARE ANGRY THAT WE
SUGGEST CERTAIN TREATMENTS OR WE
SUGGEST THEY GET VACCINATED THEY
GET BETTER.
IT HAS A DIFFERENT FEEL TO IT WE
HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS THAT GET
QUITE ANGRY.
WE HAVE TO LIMIT VISITORS AND
JUST A LOT OF RAGE AND NOT
REALLY WHAT WE WENT INTO
MEDICINE FOR.
WE THINK WE WOULD HAVE MORE
RESPECT AND UNDERSTANDING.
THERE'S JUST A LOT OF ANGER OUT
THERE RIGHT NOW AND I CAN
UNDERSTAND IT'S PRETTY
STRESSFUL, BUT ONCE AGAIN IF
THEY WOULD LISTEN TO THE SCIENCE
AND GET VACCINATED, A LOT OF
THIS WOULD NOT BE A PROBLEM.
>> I'M SO SORRY.
IT'S REALLY HARD TO HEAR YOU
DESCRIBE THAT.
IT'S SORT OF A THANKLESS JOB AND
IT SHOULDN'T BE BECAUSE WHAT YOU
AND YOUR STAFF ARE DOING IS SO
HEROIC, GETTING PEOPLE THROUGH
THIS, KEEPING THEM ALIVE, DOING
EVERYTHING YOU CAN AND THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR TALKING ABOU